maasai herders scatter as soldiers open
fire in loliondo it's on the outskirts
of the serengeti national park a unesco
world heritage site
they've been demonstrating against a
government exercise to mark off
ancestral grazing lands to create a
private hunting reserve activists say
dozens of protesters were shot and
wounded
the people believe that the land
belonged to them and the government is
saying that the land is the government
land so that is really where the problem
is and
i think then if it was to be there are
very clear procedures in the laws of
tanzania on how to how to protect the
land from
or change the categories of land from
the village land to
reserve land but the issue is the whole
procedures are not being followed
after 200 000 people visit the serengeti
every year generating millions of
dollars in income
that's increased competition for land on
the edge of the national park
thousands of maasai families were forced
to leave their villages in 2009 so that
an emirati company could organize
hunting trips to loliondo
that deal was cancelled eight years
later after allegations of corruption
the government says human activity is
putting pressure on wildlife in the
serengeti national park
it denies trying to evict maasai and
says it's offered to resettle
communities away from their historic
homeland
but the maasai say the land belongs to
them and isn't for sale for elite
tourism barbara angopa al jazeera
leader and joins me now from nairobi
good to have you with us on the program
sir let's just clarify first if if you
could tell us
uh have any maasai warriors in your
community members been hurt or injured
in this government operation
thank you very much
that is indeed the fact
over 30
young men and old men as well have been
injured in this operation
and many have been taken to nearby
hospitals and they are receiving
treatment right now
some have very serious injuries and
broken legs broken limbs
and torn muscles because of
[Music]
bullets
and so many have
sustained very very serious injuries
okay so the government operation
the government operation happened on an
area of land that we have been reporting
on can you confirm to us who actually
owns the land or who is legally allowed
to live on that land or use that land
by law
and by law i mean land law
and
[Music]
local government law
all affirm that
land belongs to the villages
and villages means
locally established
villages
where people in diabetes so
the rightful warners of the land
are the messiah communities in london so
tell us
what sort of conversation
have the maasai had with the government
over
taking over this land has there ever
been a conversation
about the government taking this land
back
the government
has for a long time wanted to take uh
disneyland
for the claims of conservation
and in a way they've made this decision
quite a long time ago
and the community has always been saying
we have not been consulted
or
asked to participate
as much
and
so there's not been a very open dialogue
between the community and the government
only quite recently in 2016
2018
the government actually asked the people
to present their opinion on how
consultation can be done and the
community actually presented the opinion
to the government it has never been
implemented
and also
this year
about two weeks ago
the community presented their proposals
to the government on how this can be
solved the conflict
conservation and community level use can
be all accommodated and the government
has not given any feedback yet
until when we have seen this operation
taking place how do you think then
how do you think sir this is going to be
resolved if you're saying that the
community has offered suggestions and
solutions and uh the government itself
has not come back to you in any form of
conversation or in written word
how do you see this actually being
resolved
one the government
must
uh actually take into account and
consider very highly the community
recommendations
and
for now the government must stop this
operation which is going on in lolion
and must cease it so that they can open
um
a dialogue on how to jointly resolve
this but generally
the community needs this land they have
already given away serengeti
in 1959 for conservation and now they
need this land for their own survival
and
the only way conservation can be done is
by actually
asking the people
how they should do it jointly
so
one thing the government must seize this
operation and they must open the
dialogue more broadly but also they
should
understand that the community really
needs this land for their own survival
we shall keep a very close eye on the
story for the moment yannick
thank you for joining us
thank you very much